[Music]
because I have only spoken to Dave Rubin
on camera about 15 times in the last two
weeks I insisted that Dave you come into
the studio thank you for obliging me
Knowles let's wrap it all up let's wrap
it we've talked a lot lately we've left
a couple open ends here people don't
know what we think about so you don't
know let's wrap it all up shake hands
and I'll see you in a couple years
I actually I do want to wrap it up in
the sense that read your book I very
much enjoyed it don't I bring this book
by Dave Rubin if you don't have it
already
then give Dave your money he's already
sold a zillion copies of it let him a
million one that's really I really
enjoyed reading it Thanks
but yellows I assume we have some
disagreement we may have some
disagreements and you still enjoyed it
and I burn it is shocking I'm gonna burn
it afterward I'm gonna light my cigars
on it but I wanted to read it before I
burned it I appreciate that
Dave you have come yeah like I actually
didn't realize how conservative you had
become until I read the play this is
kind of odd I've known you a long time
you know why don't everything I didn't
realize how conservative you had become
you have gone from progressive liberal
Young Turks guy to classical liberal
even I sort of would quibble even with
that a little bit maybe it's in some
ways more conservative yeah I want to be
the closer man yeah I want to bring you
all the way full-on conservative how can
I do it well knows I have told you and
the daily wire crew repeatedly on camera
over the years when we've done election
things together and you know you know
midterm things whatever it is that I'll
probably end up being the furthest right
you will though it's guaranteed yeah cuz
I know how evil that yes I mean the
truth is I don't take any great pleasure
in the fact that I've been right about
almost everything for the last five
years because in a weird way it almost
feels like I'm behind the curve like I
was ahead of the curve so I'm behind it
like we write a book I finished writing
that book last July we're now in July of
2020 so I finished writing and I handed
in the manuscript the last day of July
2019 yeah and then the publishing
process takes so long that you have to
just sit on those ideas and then
suddenly it comes out in April of this
year and then I'm on a book tour for a
month and on all these TV shows where
everyone's like oh these are interesting
ideas and I'm like well yeah but they
were interesting five years ago when I
really was talking about it right so so
in that regard I have moved yeah I will
gladly concede to you at this point that
in effect that book which is a defense
of classical liberalism is is really a
defense of conservatism at this point we
have a couple policy points that we
disagree on you know like the the
pro-life and pro-choice stuff stuff like
that but you know there's there are
conservatives like Rudy Giuliani like
Heather McDonald that have a pro-choice
position the conservative movement
actually is liberal in the sense that
there
is liberal in the in the right sense of
liberalism yeah in that there is some
room to disagree she told me where that
is on the left anymore it doesn't exist
and and I know people could say but Dave
you're friends with a couple of public
liberals that are but they're all hated
by the left yeah the people that will
burn their when they come to burn down
Bill Maher's house who's it gonna be is
it gonna be the lefties or is it going
to be the conservative right we're gonna
be the lefties who's gonna burn down
Ellen DeGeneres's mansion it's gonna be
the left who's gonna burn down the the
leftist mayor of LA it's still gonna be
the LMRA anti fire one of these he can
he can get down on his yes and pray to
them all he wants and it's still gonna
be them all of the Hollywood people yeah
that do these fake videos about how much
how tolerant diverse and well first up
they never give up their jobs right so
they would all walk away if you really
believed it how could you be a white
actor in Hollywood you don't have to
walk away but they're all doing it
because it's a hostage situation yeah
they're doing it to pay penance so that
maybe it buys them some time and that
that's just the sad reality of what
liberalism has become so if you want to
close the deal on this thing I think all
you have to do is live up to the to the
things that you guys talked about really
I don't know if someone says me Dave
you're a conservative now well three
years ago that would have bothered me
now it's like oh by conservative you
mean I'm trying to conserve the founding
principles of the United States I'm and
reserve free speech a history I mean the
statues I mean it's funny because
they're all these debates and I would
like to get into it on what is a
conservative what is a liberal what is
the kind of liberal view of human nature
and the conservative view where does it
disagree where all these blah blah blah
and and conservatives love nothing more
than disagreeing over what conservatism
means but Rogers never sat with some
libertarians just oh I know I mean the
libertarians I mean I managed I loved
him you know but it's very submit by a
Roger Scruton the late philosopher Roger
Scruton he had this great answer on its
what is conservatives well you know I
think conservatives want to
things I thought well that is so
delightfully simple and as the statues
are falling down it reminds me that I
like I don't care that much about the
taxes I want low taxes as much as
anybody but I don't wake up in a sweat
over the marginal tax rates and even the
individual policy issues just like
that's kind of secondary do do you want
to keep your country or do you want to
tear down statues yeah if you're gonna
tear down statues then I'm not with you
I mean even I'll give you an example of
this I don't if you saw this Ron Johnson
Republican senator he wants to make
Juneteenth which is now the most
important holiday ever in the history of
America even though most people hadn't
heard of it until two weeks ago yeah he
wants to make Juneteenth a federal
holiday you don't want to lose any money
he doesn't want to give people another
holiday so he wants to cancel Columbus
Day that is an affront to the Knowles
family it is an affront to the Knowles
family to the Italian people and he's
beyond that to America yeah
it seems like a trivial issue but to me
that guy I that guy should be out of the
Senate he just doesn't well it's not a
trivial issue because what it is is the
whittling away of anything and
everything that we know to be American
yeah and what's odd about this is you
know we should be leery of sort of bad
movements that have leaders but this
strikes me as a bad movement that
doesn't have a leader and it's almost by
design so it's like there's nobody
really publicly at the head of the
progressive movement anymore cuz where's
Bernie been for the last couple months
sort of m.i.a there's nobody really at
the head of BLM yeah it's sort of this
headless monster so that it can be
anything and everything to anyone that
it wants to be so you know it's like
when they're saying well we're gonna
tear down all the statues then the New
York Times like writes well they don't
mean all the statues and then it's like
well you can't really you can't really
compare that statement to anyone's
statement because it's all intentionally
designed to be confusing right so when
they try look if you want to tell me
we're gonna take down statues we're
gonna have a true national conversation
about taking down certain statutes now I
would personally I'm for leaving them
all up yes even even the bad Confederate
ones I would still be for leaving them
up and you could put a counter plaque
next to it or even a counter monument
you know because the idea I used to say
that and this is this will show you how
you go from sort of liberal to
conservative yeah a year ago I would
have said before all the monuments were
being torn down like like you know Isis
likes to do that but before this was all
happening I would have said you know if
you want to take some of them and move
them to museums yeah that would be okay
right I really would have been okay with
that and now I really realize that's a
very short-sighted thing understanding
what this movement is because the
movement will also burn down the museum
yeah
yeah so so that this is why for
conservatives who want to conserve yeah
I would say there is not an inch you can
give anymore and and if anything you
need to even be pushing harder than
you've ever pushing when I say you I
actually mean we at this press right
like again for whatever little political
differences we have even though I'm not
I'm not trying to tribal I to realize
Horsham it's not a little issue but it's
a but it's a political issue yeah and
then I've come pretty far on abortion by
the way I mean you you all have come
further than I realized on abortion it
is a life I'm not doing the sperm meets
the egg I mean you know I mean I'm in
the process right now of having kids and
I'm married to a guy we can't do it
biologically I know a lot about the
sperm I'm no scientist but I mean I know
now a lot about the process right like
the scientific process Hagen this I mean
when do we know this thing gets together
and then when we can start doing tests
on things like you can't tell me that's
not a life without going to deep into
the abortion thing because I know
there's a lot of stuff we want to talk
about I just feel that in a pluralistic
society you have to have some level of
choice I think 12 weeks it sucks it's
not good it's somewhat arbitrary I can
seed all of those things but unless you
want to live in a theocracy where you're
not going to give people those choices
but yeah I know I know we just don't see
eye to them you're gonna you know I'm
actually sort of I'm so
taken with this argument that you're
making because you are because you've
seen it because you're actually in this
kind of very modern scientific process
that you can't deny it you don't deny
and so when does it start I mean yeah
what am i paying all this money in order
you're gonna put my sperm with the egg
yes whom something happens at that
moment right I'm not denying that that's
lie so you're saying its life at
conception and you've gone from now you
are much more in the pro-life direction
than even some Republicans I mean some
Republicans would say well I am pro-life
at viability
you've gone much route you're saying I'm
saying 12 weeks and I know that is
somewhat arbitrary I used to say 20
weeks because there was a lot of science
that the fetus could feel pain then and
I debated this with Shapiro and any what
he said was he said well wait a minute
but you're saying it is a life and
you're saying I've had 20 weeks it's
okay then why night 18 and I said well
you this is what public this is why
public policy and philosophy yeah aren't
exactly the same thing like public
policy you can have a philosophical or
lens that you view the world through and
then you have to have policy that
hopefully it can get enough people to
agree with it yeah and and that's just a
sucky it's a sucky thing but but to me
the only alternative is that you're
gonna have to just have eat except tell
people what to do and also you know if
you if you make it completely illegal we
know that people will still do it that's
not a reason to make it legal it's just
a reality we know that people will do it
and we know that it will be highly
dangerous for people that don't have
certain economic means and I'm not gonna
be that it would be highly dangerous
well if you have if it's illegal and you
don't have a lot of money you're gonna
do some really weird stuff oh you don't
know about hangers in back alleys
everybody yeah I've agree with
everything you've said so far just about
I mean on this kind of point the
different public policy and philosophy
but I think this is a lie that the
pro-choice movement has foisted on us
that I once believed that most people
believe that hundreds thousands of women
are dying from back-alley abortions
didn't happen 1973 1972 rather year
before Roe vs. Wade do you know how many
women died of back-alley abortions how
many 39 Gina how many died of legal
abortions I think the number was 26 was
23 or 26 I was not told you were gonna
be using fax I know I try not to
but this is what this was talking to you
because if you tally up the percentage
of states where abortion was legal and
illegal at the time it was you were
statistically as likely to die of a
legal abortion as an illegal one now
this is I mean they about this they
teach you this in every public health
class or whatever and it's just total BS
and so but I grant I grant the other
premises which is you're in a
pluralistic society you got to get
people to come around that's where most
people who agree is you should be able
to have some abortion but not so you got
to pick an arbitrary date my prediction
though yeah is I think you're gonna be a
hundred percent fully pro-life
we shall see we shall see we shall see
yeah that's why I find this one to be so
interesting also because one of the
things that has also shown me that
conservatives are more open-minded than
progressives lefties whatever you want
to say with liberals like it also is
getting difficult for me to save the
world the word liberal yes right it's
getting increasingly hard for me to do
that because I have to keep I don't like
having to keep explaining myself over
and over again and and it's just hard
the word has been butchered yeah the
word has truly been abused but this this
argument it's like we could do this all
day long and your audience would watch
it and obviously I would suspect them
most of your audience would agree with
you that's but I think a lot of them
would say all right Dave's making some
interesting arguments and this is just
what it's all about yeah on the Left
there's almost no ability to do that who
are the pro-life democrats that are left
are there any I'm pretty sure in the
Democratic platform I don't know that
they fully got it in in 2016 right but
they wanted no limits on anything you
know we've got Ralph Northam with
post-birth de Bourg yeah I've said to
fourth trimester ah yeah fourth
trimester what do we used to call that
but you know I've talked about this with
men it's like the arguments that you
guys make I'm not saying that there's
holes in your argument yeah but that's
not totally what has moved me what has
moved me more so is the lunacy of the
Left er yeah right because these are an
arguments these are crazy positions that
they take and and they have no
philosophical backing for it they just
feel it's the right thing to do and that
you hate women Yeah right and when I see
that it's like okay so I can either be
part of that yeah or there's this other
group of people who we can at least do
this dance with and let's not forget
Rudy Giuliani who as I said is he he
takes the same position 12 rhymes I just
had him on my show and we talked about
it it's only eight years ago that he was
the leading at one time leading
candidate to be president on the
Republican side now his campaign failed
for many reasons because of strategies
Bank you don't win any states and don't
do anything in the middle of the country
yeah bad mood so but put that aside but
that shows you that Republicans do have
a plural or a plurality of opinion on
this yes yeah I think that's true
and I loved this point you make in the
book about about debates too because
this is you you make this point that
like people don't it's not like you you
debate an issue right and then you're
kind of Duke it out and then you're like
okay well I was wrong and you were right
um and I I've never done that I've never
sat and been like yeah you were totally
right and I was totally wrong yeah good
me and yet I have been beaten in more
debates and I will admit and and then
you go home and you're like ah man Sally
was so wrong yes Ali was weldment except
yeah but and oh yeah oh no she was
completely right and I was wrong and
then you only admit that later you don't
do it at the time right and the one
thing I love is like about your whole
show and the whole book and everything
is this kind of personal element that I
I don't think people get convinced of
new ideas or whatever strictly because
they read some argument on a computer
think it is about people and the the
people on your former side of the
political aisle yeah have been very
vindictive and I think there are jerks
on the right too but I think they have
been more vindictive than the people on
the right yeah
you would know better that yeah I mean
I'm I talk about this in the book
obviously but I was shocked to find out
when I first started talking about this
stuff five years ago and I'm going hey
left these liberals what's happening to
us why are we be platforming people why
are we shouting speakers down why are we
taking out opinions that we marginally
disagree with not that you know it
wasn't just we weren't just taking out
the scary conservatives we're suddenly
taken out liberals who just think one
other thing you know were taken out
ayaan Hirsi Ali because she talks about
radical Islam like strange things even
though she's exactly what a true
feminist yeah right he is supposed to be
if you had the the dictionary definition
of a feminist who's for equality and
female empowerment I mean they should
you want to put up a statue right I will
gladly put up a statue of ayaan Hirsi
Ali I started talking about that and yes
I I got some people that were interested
and then some conservatives kind of
coming over and going oh this is this is
interesting he doesn't absolutely hate
us and he's a liberal it doesn't really
make sense but the absolute deluge of
yeah crazed yeah hate that I was getting
that I still get the amount of what
ready ready for people you know that are
dedicated to destroying me and lying
about me and manipulating what I say and
YouTube selectively editing things so it
sounds like I said the reverse of what I
say like I'm not saying that's a purely
left this thing like of course there's a
version of that on the right but the
hate like why is it that all the hate I
get online now is from people with
pronouns in their BIOS pronouns and and
you know they always say they're
democratic socialists and it's he him
him she it whatever it is see ya Zi way
I don't even know what that is
all of this also by the way it seems
more offensive
yeah then if you were to just be if you
were to just call someone a he and their
a she like
you go on facebook on my fan page or
whatever it is you can select your
gender one of them is it but is one of
them literally is it at least that was
at one time I don't know still have it
now it's all but but this is such a
this is an end of liberal world that
we're living in it's an end of secular
world that at the end you won't know
anything about anything and we just did
your Prager you show on the club on 1984
which I guess is gonna come out after
this yeah yeah but it was so much it was
so much of what's happening yeah right
now words won't have any meaning the
time will be confused history will mean
nothing yes we'll go the memory hole
we're gonna go from one crisis yeah you
know we killed soleimani World War three
Bolton was installed World War three
like we're always having World War three
5g wrestling out in the Kurds all right
and that's gonna be World War three and
right and yet here we are yeah and and I
think there is a reason for that
all that the secular the purely secular
world has left is just endless chaos to
keep us watching I want to hone in on
that it's not a fun thing for me to say
by the way I won't but that's that's
very interesting to me because that word
secular I remember first time I met you
Dave Rubin liberal beautifully colorist
big atheist I would we talk about yeah
yeah yeah but now you're kind of
criticizing the secular worldview have
you has there been movement here well I
would well I make the argument yeah you
you read night as I think you as I as I
saw them all up to you yeah yeah I think
you know the answer yeah that was good
look a world that doesn't have belief
outside of itself is going to lead to
exactly where we are right now all of
these people that think that they can
solve all of our problems through
politics that think that somehow
everybody before them what their parents
their grandparents people who lived in
unimaginably awful circumstances usually
right like why did your great
grandparents or grandparents come here
right I'm sure like Wes I don't want to
press people through Columbus and
through Columbus Day they wanted to
oppress other people and then also bring
delicious delicious super sada yeah but
but really I like I don't know the
answer to this but I can guarantee I
mean it punched me if I'm running you
can
I'm gonna guess that where is it your
great grandparents or grandparents so on
that barb on the Italian side it was
yeah I guess would be great grandparents
came over from Sicily and Calabria
okay I'm gonna guess that they had a
suitcase and that's it did they come
over with a lot of money did they come
over a lot of stuff not even remember
they got here not even a suitcase I mean
not nothing like ten bucks or whatever
you know same with my great-grand dad is
the American story those people lived
through so much worse than these idiot
social justice warriors we're on iPhones
all day pretending they're oppressed and
yet they're the ones that are erasing
their own families history
yeah that's what they're doing and and
there's a reason because when you get to
the end of just pure secularism like why
is it right well you feel it's right
yeah well then you're gonna end up with
everything nothing is going to make
sense the the great Douglas Murray talks
about this that the when the barbarians
are at the gate yeah we're gonna be
debating what gender pronouns to call
them and I love that line like they're
gonna be bashing that's how the doors
it's it literally this is what's
happening right now they're gonna be
bashing down the doors of the last the
last bastion of freedom and what are we
going to be doing hey guys the guys
fashion the doors she's a she's gonna
say is it and and that is what we're
gonna be doing and they're preying on
that so to directly answer your question
I believe that to have a functional
society you must believe in something
outside of yourself which by the way
it's a conservative belief but it is a
class of a liberal belief as well
because the founders who were mostly
classical liberals in effect they they
believe what did they believe they
believed in God given right yeah
this estate didn't make you free we're
just gonna set up a system to protect
freedom yeah we'd but we didn't hand it
to you because if we handed it to you
well congratulations it's ours to take
that this is such a good point that
Alexei de Tocqueville makes - in
democracy in America which is when you
read the founders they riu know at least
the way people are talking about them
now it's like there are 2020
libertarians you know but it's but you
say classical broilers a day a stick or
something yeah and I think that's true
but the point Tocqueville makes is that
they talk like John Locke but they act
like Edmund Burke
so they walk like the liberal but they
act like the conservative and and and
it's kind of what you're describing
which is because isn't that the best way
to form a society in a way right like
having this country it's right well to
have that push and pull
yeah understanding the past and the
things that we built and then also
trying to push to free as many people as
possible like these are the same people
were saying god-given rights and then
what were they also doing separation of
church and state that yeah what an
incredible what and I don't think they
had separation of church and state
well they had their private beliefs
about God and religion but what do you
mean they they hadn't known so I mean I
like I grant like half of this but they
had no established church ever at the
federal government yeah and I think some
people interpret that to mean that you
know there was this hardrock rib
separation of church and state Thomas
Jefferson in one letter references the
separation of church and state but in in
effect when they ratified the
Constitution one of the reasons they
don't establish a church at the top
philosophical reasons aside is there
were established churches in the States
so there were states that actually had
established churches and it was it was
not only a way to protect people's
private religious beliefs but also to
protect the rights of states to have
their own religious laws and things like
that so so you think they did it for a
well then why write what you write it in
for federalism in effect okay so I'm
okay with that yeah churches right yeah
because this this point that you've made
on the push and pull like that it's the
point John Henry Newman made one of the
great thinkers for once an Anglican then
a Catholic I mean I'm a totally improper
all my dead friends yeah every Newman
makes this point though you have
articulated perfectly which is you can
only lean on something that offers
resistance so you can only have all
these kind of liberal ideas that you
have in the declaration it's got to be
leaning on this tradition that we've got
this kind of civilization and it's I
think it's kind of why if we were in
1776 right now we'd we would say oh yes
I'd love these liberal ideas I'm a
liberal right but and yet today you
hesitate to call yourself a liberal
because it seems to me that tradition is
doesn't offer any resistance anymore and
now you get the blue hair is screaming
about pronouns well I'll go with you on
that so that you can quote me one day
when I'm dead which is because the
progressives just want to progress yeah
so if you need push and pull if a
healthy society needs push and pull so
that it doesn't go completely haywire
well then you'd have conservatism
defending the old yeah versus liberalism
trying to expand the new or something
right something like that but
progressives are for progress and that
is a meaningless phrase you're for
progress what do you mean well I'm for
progress I'm going this way well you
know there might be a cliff over there
yeah but I'm progressing and what
they're do what we're doing right now is
just progressing off the cliff yeah they
and and to really elicit the point
they've made sure that there is no
counter-argument to their ideology right
what what what counter-argument would a
progressive allow they don't which is
why they tell you that everything that
doesn't go along with white fragility
and the patriarchy and the gender
pronouns and the intersectional matrix
that is completely insane yeah they'll
tell you it's all racist and bigoted and
homophobic so they've eliminated the
pushback right they've eliminated half
of the equation and they're in a car
that is clearly gonna go off a cliff and
I think for all of us that care about
freedom that care about this country
that want to live whatever life we want
to live it's all of us versus the
progressive yeah that really is true now
I would say when I say all of us I would
say that excludes like the tiniest
fringe of the whatever that far-right
thing is which really is far left by the
way because it shares a lot of
similarities well it is because when
people say far right they always be in
the KKK or these white supremacists or
something but that's collectivist yeah
that's collectivist which is an idea of
the left when people say far-right what
you really mean is like the ultimate
libertarian like a Michael malleus sort
of ancap right if you right if we were
looking at pure Lee I know the far I
want to hear your version of it now also
yeah well well that's what I would say
that if you really the way I understand
it is that if you look at left and right
if you strip away a lot of the nonsense
it's that the left is collectivist and
we can go really far left into crazy
collectivism yeah
the right is really individualist and we
can go really far into an anarchy
basically so when people say far right I
think they actually mean far left this
is sort of what people call the
horseshoes yes yeah come around yeah I
agree with the word what am I missing
there so I give this room here I think
the horseshoe theory thing is right and
I think I think it's actually because
that's the way we think about it these
days that we get very confused because
we say wait a second a neo-nazi in some
ways his right wing because I don't know
he's a big tough guy wants to be real
macho he wants to go to tradition but
it's also clearly a left-winger because
he's usually an atheist
he's a collectivist he you know is
worships the state so it just doesn't
quite make sense and then you get this
horseshoe idea but I think I think part
of the reason we fall into that
confusion is because we're thinking
surely in a modern lens mmm so we're
only thinking we're kind of just
assuming modern or you can say liberal
or you know moving out of that realism
premises that the individual is the
building block of society and so you can
have at the one end the anarchist who
says the individual is the building
block of society we should only just
have individuals floating around a free
space no rules and then the collectivist
who says the individual is the building
block of society and that's why we've
got to gather them all up on the commune
or in the fashi like the fascists do and
but both of them still have the same
premise that it's all about the
individual and I think what
conservatives are beginning to recognize
myself included I mean I wouldn't have
thought this a few years ago even is
maybe it's not just all about the
individual yeah maybe of course the
individual is a sovereign creature
creature of God but maybe there is
something else to conserve like families
and institutions well I'm with you
because it's like there's this weird
thing that happened in the 60s in the
80s which is you had the hippies of the
60s in the yuppies of the 80s you had
the lefties who loved the Soviet Union
and then you got a bunch of people
voting for Reagan and the it's either
you can look at that as a contradiction
or it's kind of two sides of the same
coin the social individualism of the
hippies and the economic individualism
of the Reaganites maybe it's just the
hippies grew up and wanted a nice car
that is what it is then they realize and
can do drugs and have sex with everyone
and all of those things right you can do
that as a hippie and we know this with
the baby boomers what did they become
they became the religion of nationalism
to be Julis all of that stuff yeah so I
don't even know are we disagree yes
because I'm saying that's bad so yeah my
point on that is because it seems to me
it all presumes that the point of
society should be self-interest
hmm
but I actually think there is more to
that I think there should be public
spiritedness yeah I think we should want
to serve others I don't think you know
especially since I am Catholic and you
know I have a religion that I don't
think I just own myself and the you know
my life is a free gift from God and I'm
not gonna have a whole lot to say when I
go out of this world either yeah and so
I think I have I think instead of
viewing the world primarily through a
lens of Rights either the crazy positive
rights of the left or even the negative
rights that the room that the right wing
likes to talk about I view it primarily
through a lens of obligation duty
loyalty
I've got affection for my friends I've
got an affection for my family at the
highest level I've got an affection to
my country called patriotism much now
that and oh now you're going into the
film going and now I'm the far right now
I am the far right and I just think like
that idea is not even on the spectrum
that okay yeah so that's why look you're
doing anything with like a spectrum is
this in this and it's like we all got to
be within that and the Overton Window is
this and it's dimensional and all that
of course you know a lot of what we have
to do as people that try to communicate
these ideas is we have to simplify them
in a way so that the app and I hate
saying the average person but like the
person wanted the hoi polloi know but
but we have to write so like we have to
sometimes when I say the left yeah do I
mean every single person yes not
naturally when I say it about the left
of words but but but I think so yeah I
don't even think we're that far off I
think you would have an interesting
conversation would say like the realign
Randy and yet I because they would have
an issue with that yeah
although they would say what you call
self-interest they would say it's
rational self-interest that Ben does
cause community building and everything
else yeah we can sort of put that aside
for now
but again these things are the things
that should be being discussed in public
policy these are the things that should
be debated
imagine if Biden and Trump actually
debated these oh could you imagine I
can't imagine cuz I don't think I mean
there's so many reasons I can't imagine
it would be bananas I don't even think
the debates are gonna happen that's a
separate issue and I want to get back to
that because I I think you're right yeah
well look I mean the fact that the
Democrats now
basically a virtual convention virtual
campaign Biden sunny wouldn't campaign
he's in the basement in a virtual
convention and he's just a tool at this
point he's just a tool in that he's not
running the show here and everyone knows
he's having cognitive decline and
they're all pretending he doesn't how
Dan it's actually I would dare I know I
you know what the truth is my grandma
when I was doing stand-up in New York so
I had time yeah I was working mostly at
night so I had time during the day but I
was free and my grandma had the
beginnings of dementia she lived in
Manhattan and I would spend almost every
day with her and I would be taking her
to doctors when we first realized she
was repeating herself she was forgetting
words she was you know she'd start
saying something and then you know three
words in couldn't remember where she was
going all those things like I've been
around that I know what that is I'm not
a doctor but like everyone knows
something is wrong everyone now everyone
knows it and they're pretending it's not
true just so that they could get him to
be President so the second he's
president in effect he either steps down
or they hide him so that the VP or the
party apparatus or whatever that thing
that monster is can run the show and by
the way you know this is the scary part
of what's going on here it's like boo
boo the Democratic Party did for all its
flaws and and the awfulness and
corruption it did fight back through the
electoral process the oncoming socialist
onslaught it did it did and yet it's now
being eaten away from the inside because
he's obviously gonna choose some
progressive nut bag as his VP you think
it's yeah and it's like can Biden stand
up to any of this Joe Biden who said at
the LGBT equality forum that it's not
what gender you are that should decide
what prison you go to it's what gender
you identify as orange is the new black
it's gonna be amazing
I mean these people are bananas but
again we're debating everything young
we're debating things that should not be
debated or that is to bring this fully
around to the beginning that is because
this is the end of liberalism we're in
the end of liberalism yeah and and my
hope is that if conservatism I do
believe that the future of the West is a
center-right future and and it will be
my job I think and people that are more
in line with my thinking to be the ones
that are pushing back when it starts
getting to conservative that and but but
I
think people like you will welcome that
and that will be a beautiful thing yeah
that's that's a great point because it I
don't think you're the only one I'd I
mean you were kind of at a head of how
to be I've met one other I know there's
one nobody has handsome yeah yeah you
were you were at a head of it but
there's a reason that your show is
extremely popular right which is that a
lot of people yeah
left the left as your video says and and
have embraced these liberal ideas and
have kind of recognized that liberalism
as you say is crumbling all around us
and there's gonna be something that
comes after this I know our pal at drew
Clavin says that he always thought Trump
was not gonna be the beginning of
something he was kind of the end of
something he's clearing the table
basically and resetting us so that we
can talk about this and you know to
quote another dead friend of mine the
Cardinal Manning a great great thinker
he said a counter I know you really just
need a little bug in the corner Colonel
Manning of this line he said at bottom
all human conflict is theological and
this I notice is something that keeps
coming up as you as you're talking which
is a secular issue there's nothing to
lean on there's nothing to believe in
there's no no objective reality so and
you mentioned Douglas Murray you're very
much alive friend he's British it's
weird living British thinker those three
don't go together very exciting so he
has this line yeah which maybe you would
fall into too is that he says he's a
Christian atheist direct cultural
Christian or something like that yeah
basically saying a Christianity is good
it shaped the West we need it but I
myself cannot believe yeah well Douglass
also happens to be gay yeah that's right
it is it is just a part of him it is not
the sum of who he is you know I hate
until you said that I had forgotten and
it's kind of like with you I sometimes
forget because you don't make it the
centerpiece of your identity you're not
gonna believe this no I'm not constantly
thinking about your sexuality either why
not you know thinking of me it's a lot
to be thinking no I'd be insulted on my
show today when do have your knowledge
thank you but I think there is look
Douglas I I don't know I've interviewed
Douglas a million times we were very
good friends I don't know of a position
that Douglas holds that is different
than my believe right I I've yet to find
one now Douglas in a in a British sense
he calls himself a conservative yeah
which you know again without getting
lost in that thing it's it's basically
what an old-school liberal is I have no
problem if that's what conservatism is
and if acknowledging as Douglas is doing
in that idea
knowledge about judeo-christian values
and has been talks about the the balance
between Jerusalem and Athens
if acknowledging all of that is what
makes the world go yeah is what gives us
the underpinning to free people well
then I'm a conservative and that's but
do you do you think like is it enough to
acknowledge as I think it's like every
sensible person I know today does as you
do as Jordan Pederson does that you need
religion and you need like a good
religion society cannot organize around
anything else it needs really simply
cannot do it that doesn't mean that
there aren't people individual people
yeah sam harris for example i believe
him to be a deeply moral person he's
yeah good buddy of mine weed yeah don't
many times you know like i don't know if
you would want that he we've had drinks
many times just drink i don't know that
i'm totally a guy breed of now just say
I did huh um but but Michael Shermer
Peter Burgos he and I know plenty of
atheists who are good moral decent
people those ideas cannot organize
societies they simply cannot the idea
that you can mindfully meditate yeah the
way to a good society simply does not
work and that aside that by the way is
is why Jordan Peterson exploded the way
he did yeah and that also by the way
with Jordan being mi a right now is why
it feels like there's a hole in the
internet doesn't it it does because
Jordan not only did he he show people
that that personal responsibility clean
your room is important but he also said
to them very something outside of you
know there is some driving force outside
of you that has been churned through the
generations I believe there is there
Bisaya 'test sand and the philosophers
and the atheists and all these people
they can come up with all the good stuff
they want they can meditate and they can
think that cannot it offers no defense
when the barbarians are at the gate and
that's why every liberal institution is
being destroyed what is being destroyed
right now Harvard academia oh yeah the
New York Times is every day the New York
Times it's like the New York Times is
really in a core implosion right now you
know how when there's a core implosion
like when I when like a bit like Star
Wars or a planet it is like an imploding
it like takes a little while
then it caught the first bit yeah I'm
sure there's a scientific principle on
that like you know there's a while where
it's like getting hotter and hotter and
hotter and then it crosses that Rubicon
and then and then just the New York
Times every day Wow you guys are like we
all saw it but now this is just beyond
bananas but it is going to eat out this
took a turn hold on it el down here
sorry sorry yeah we don't talk about
sexuality yeah it is going to dismantle
and destroy every liberal institution
and the only things that will exist
after will have been the things that
inoculated themselves from social
justice and that will be a couple
conservative institutions once you let
just yesterday on so well so just
yesterday on Twitter did you see this
thing some guy his wife or his
girlfriend is applying for a job at
Twitter and she he said she's a lefty
but she screenshot where they wanted to
know to be hired by Twitter your gender
identity and one who was like I'm
cisgendered heteronormative I'm a
giraffe yeah joy like it was like the
eight things and and you look at them
and no sensible person can make any
sense out of them yeah but even putting
at that aside once you let social
justice in that these things matter yeah
if you're working a Twitter I want you
to be a good coder when I hire people I
have a small business right there what
gender identity where I don't care what
color you are small business that's
doing very well by the way locals calm
vocals calm and and my production
company they're both doing great we have
zero debt we're growing and guess what
it's because I hire you're not gonna
believe this Knowles I hire qualified
people not people based on their gender
identity so you're a felon is what
you're saying I'm sure now well even in
California right now what are they
trying to do what's our local LA
assembly trying to do right now they
want the equal protections to be taken
out because they write discrimination to
be encoded in our law so as this is all
crumbling I I mean you've put it so well
yeah my question is is it enough to
realize intellectually all those things
are true or must you go further is is
enough to say God must exist for society
and religion must exist for society or
must you go further and say I believe in
God I will practice Christianity right
so I think that I I think this is a
great question that I think the only
real answer and this
where maybe I fall a little more on the
individualist side than you is that I
don't think everyone has to play the
exact same role in it so a metaphor I
could take with this would be like right
now with what we're seeing with big tech
there are arguments for regulation there
are arguments for stripping rights there
are arguments for competition I like all
of that like I like the fact that Prager
has taken a slightly different position
they're doing some legal stuff while I
started a start-up and Tucker wants more
government intervention we're all allies
in a fight we're all doing it
differently somebody's in the helicopter
somebody's on the ground so I would say
to answer your question there's going
you you're gonna have to have a
religious backing for this and people
that really mean that from a Christian
perspective a personal relationship with
God that's a little bit different than a
than a Jewish perspective like you and
Ben obviously want to live in the exact
same society but I correct me if I'm
wrong I don't think that includes that
you want to convert him per se well do I
personally want to or politically want
to convert him I personally like to / I
guess I do but yeah but I know you won't
force him to convert not yet we've been
through that yeah it's your product
right I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't hold
a sword in his throat and say you better
convert right as it wouldn't work anyway
but you both from your political from
your personal religious viewpoints are
trying to build something that's pretty
similar ricans yet allure yes it's
pretty freakin similar now your view of
God is more personal because that's a
Christian view of God where
international right that's different
than Ben's where I would bend from an
Orthodox Jewish perspective or mine from
a more secular Jewish perspective which
is more that it's about grappling with
God and wrestling with God that is real
literally wrestles with God right I mean
and that right so that that is just a
fundamental different thing yeah but
what I would say is I agree with your
premise and I think that you you're
gonna need a lot of people fighting it
from different ways and by the way when
when I was on tour with Jordan and he
would get asked this a lot because
people would say they always ask well
because they would say well wait a
minute you're pushing religious stories
yeah to show us something eternally true
but they would say are you religious and
he would say no he would say what to say
question mean but just let's still go in
Kermit the Frog load yeah
in effect he would say that he does he
does pray at times and moments quiet I'm
sorry but he doesn't really go to church
he doesn't so I would say he's a sort of
functional believer so and that's really
what I would say I am I'm a functional
believer because I see no way around
belief yeah I just see no way around it
anymore
it's like well you know the line there
are no atheists and fossils yeah and
there are no leftists in a reasonable
company 2020 America after you might say
yeah it's something like that so if you
can figure out a way to what we're gonna
as a society around mindful meditation
or and that's not a shot at Sam I mean
that's that is what he does it's a great
point but but it is it is that like the
idea that we can just organize all
people from all different philosophies
and ethnicities and backgrounds under
this idea that we all can sort of think
about something in a purely rational
that rationality I mean I think this is
the flaw of steven pinker argument that
rationality is the driver of humanity
it's just missing like the most
fundamental yes there is Dave I think
you I hate to say something like
flattering and complimentary I think you
actually are like the embodiment of what
society is thinking right now and you're
just like a little bit ahead of it and
it but it's like this is exactly as well
for a society I know yeah that's right
it was like so we're doomed this really
means no I mean I think that is actually
this is the path this is the path that
people are following these are the
questions they're grappling with these
are the things people are seeing and
well did you see well well thank you for
yes very nice thing to hear did you see
just the other day Chris Cuomo had that
line at the end of his show if you want
to change society you don't need someone
up there it's what you do here not at
some level that sort of sounds right in
that you should do the best you can here
but first off the idea that you'd get
spiritual advice from someone on CNN
much like much less this fake tan and
complete buffoon who by the way doesn't
act you know that you should be better
here this is the guy who faked his
coronavirus he staged his coming out of
the basement he got into a fight on the
street when somebody called in freedo in
the Hamptons you know but but putting
all that aside like that you don't that
beast the idea he was pushing was that
these things are not
linked yeah and they are linked that's
the point was the idea it was the idea
you mentioned earlier which is that the
the left the rationalists the Socialists
the 2a degrees some liberals at least
think that you can accomplish anything
through politics you can and you can't
you obviously can enslave a lot of
people yes what you can do purely
through politics is control a lot of
people most likely kill a lot of people
the idea that you could you know our
founders did it well yeah that they
freed a lot of people but yeah perfectly
as we know because we're gonna have to
support all that every single day right
but they they did and that's why I still
believe that the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence and the Bill
of Rights these are the best man-made
documents to free as many people as
possible but of course they are there I
don't think the documents themselves are
the documents were aspirational so that
I don't know that the documents are
flawed the people who wrote them didn't
do everything in their living power at
that moment to make I could have changed
a comma or to you know yeah but I read
but but I really mean that like I don't
know that I'm not arguing that there
there's anything technically wrong in
him but the people of course who wrote
them didn't live up to them every second
of every what humans do you Michael
knows live up to your greatest ideals
every second well every second you don't
yeah that's right that's obviously the
rational view of this thing and it's
just this position two of you look back
at our founding fathers and you look
back at these documents which are really
tremendous works I mean even if you
don't think they're perfect they're
really tremendous edifice that was built
up to have this country to allow people
to have a semblance of freedom and you
know and those can I do something that's
never been done in the history of the
michael noland at least you can I tell
my guy Michael over here that we're
gonna buy an extra 15 minutes are we
gonna do it can tell the other you can
tell the other guy that the paths müber
to the thing and I'll meet him oh right
that's actually cuz I was a teen minutes
you are the man I was like wait a second
okay I don't know where we're at in time
I have no sense of time or we are
exactly accurate 45 we're there no right
we must do an hour okay good I'm glad
you just started it might not like we
just in his because but this point is so
important and so I'm glad we actually
get to talk about it which is even if
you don't think that that's perfect and
these guys were perfect
first of all take a look at yourself in
the mirror but second I lots it's okay
by me
look look back on it wouldn't you be a
little grateful I mean it's even even if
you think they weren't all that good
it's brought you to this point where you
the most virtuous person who's ever
walked the face of the earth where you
get to live wouldn't you just look at I
don't think it's good that's the thing
if you really listen to what the
progressives have been saying for the
last five years think back to the
Democratic debates even though it feels
like a lifetime ago yeah remember Bernie
and Budaj edge and right Amala and that
clown I had fun yeah yeah but it does
feel like I think how we're relevant it
all feels remember we're all screaming
about it and everyone's tweeting about
it it all feels completely fills like an
old world a judge who even doesn't none
of it matters but think about it how
many times did they say anything
positive about America how many times in
the debates that they say freedom
liberty Constitution pride anything how
many times do you think we're taping
this a day or two before July 4th
how many progressives on Twitter
politicians pundits or whatever are
gonna say anything prideful about the
United States it will be even the follow
generals either they elected you think
AOC is gonna say something nice about
America on no because her base would
destroy her so every time Bernie said I
want a political revolution what he
meant was I want a revolution revolution
he kept saying political rep for every
revolution is political but he was
saying but what what but our connotation
with revolution is off with their heads
right now it's French Revolution or
American Revolution which there was a
lot of blood and what they're assuring
in they they snuck it in through the
guise of were nice or decent it's just a
political revolution not a revolution
revolution and they're so when you say
that that oh they should be grateful or
they should look back and think oh maybe
these people did something within the
semblance of something decent they don't
believe it's rises they don't believe
that the Washington Monument should be
there they don't care yeah what that
Lincoln freed the slaves they the point
is they believe this experiment to be
evil because they have been brainwashed
but I wonder if this ties back into this
point you made earlier we were talking
about the the personal relationships
they it's not just that they seem to
resent robert e lee or george washington
or st. Junipero Serra or any of tearing
down statues obsessed now it's not they
they seem to resent like everybody like
they certainly seem to resent
conservatives and they I mean there's
social science to back this up too they
will stop being friends with
conservative oh yeah much higher rating
observers will stop being friends with
them but they seem to even resent one
another they seem to resent their
parents I don't want to delve into
psychobabble but you know the plural of
anecdote is data at a certain point what
is it about that is it just personal too
I mean this is the political the
personal to quote the 60s radical well I
mean I think it's a couple things that
we've sort of talked about here it's
partly just they've removed personal
responsibility from the equation it's
it's more focused on the world as evil
and it's your job to somehow fix the
evil world yeah but it's not really
about you there's a reason that they
look a certain way I don't know this to
be a dick yeah but there's a reason they
look like slobs and their hair is a mess
and they don't take care of themselves
they clean your room yeah that's what
Jordan Peter Carl Marx was a disgusting
person actually Whitney the guy who put
a little a little a little pomade or
something I mean he was a filthy
individual yeah yeah he didn't bathe and
if you look there's a great great book
by an alive person he's not a friend of
mine but he's not a dead friend of mine
yet Paul Johnson wrote this great book
called that elections and it's all these
leftist intellectuals read history and
one thing as you say they all like look
a certain way they're filthy they wear
dirty clothing they don't take care of
themselves they don't clean their way
it's not a coincidence I spoke at
crossroads school do you know cross yeah
well in LA it is like there it is you
know it is v liberal elite this is where
all the multi multi millionaires of
Hollywood send their kids like it's been
this way for decades and it is a
progressive bastion of insanity yeah now
that's what it's become it wasn't it was
good liberal in the sense of it maybe
thirty years ago and it's become this
just insane thing so before the 2016
election I did a talk there they wanted
to have a socialist they wanted to have
a liberal a libertarian and a
conservative they brought me as the
liberal not realizing that no not really
I think that I was just going to agree
with the libertarian not ever
right and Amanda conservative Serban the
socialist that they brought and I don't
again I don't mean this in the in the
awful way it's gonna sound he was a
giant fat sweaty slob whose shirt was
disgusting who smelled he literally
smell he smelled and and we're doing our
talk and it's front of hundreds of kids
yeah and at the beginning of it the kids
are all nodding with him and applauding
him and everything and then finally when
I realized how twisted this was that
these kids who were the most privileged
in the sense of privilege meaning that
their parents have worked really really
hard in it is super expensive a colada
money so they can live in the Hollywood
Hills and also tell you how horrible
America is finally I was like I better
do something about this so then I just
started kind of jabbing him like making
some jokes about him and about socialism
it how silly it is that you guys sit
here you know basically to you know the
alladhi ideas to bet will burn down your
houses and I did a lot of it through
comedy and I kind of want it by the end
yeah but that's not a coincidence this
idea because once you remove agency and
once you remove personal responsibility
well again you're gonna be sort of in
just endless chaos they don't believe in
I know it sounds crazy but it's like
they don't every day they wake up in the
world is just a thing that's spinning
around and bah-bah-bah and then you hear
a story and you get enraged by a story
and then that can make you do anything
as opposed to people who believe in
something as imperfect as we all are you
wake up you know that universe has some
sort of order and your hope is I think
that you can do something maybe to
adjust it in a way that will be slightly
more I do what I can
I'll do what I can do my best got to do
the rest yeah something like that this
makes me desire a happy prediction for
the future and I'm gonna ask you for
your prediction of the future because as
you've just described there's this
personal responsibility component to it
to anything you know please make your
bed clean yourself read your books too
and this old idea of Liberty liberties
kind of been redefined there's this old
idea of Liberty why we have the liberal
arts education is the old ideas you're
born a slave you're a slave to your
passions on the
baby can't take care of himself he needs
his mother is very dependent when you're
a teenager you are a slave to certain
appetites you know and I'm just and as
you get yourself as you get a liberal
education you you are educated in how to
make sense of your freedom and to
control your passions paym and actually
like be a free man and now the modern
idea of of Liberty is totally the
opposite whatever whatever you want to
warn the minute you're born for you're
free in a state of nature and actually
you only become unfree when people like
put rules onion stuff so that's where we
are and that's this generation of people
that you see on college campuses I see
on college campuses you know they're
there more of them than of the four men
they love us so much I mean there's more
of the blue hairs I think at least in in
the public eye then then of the other
people so what does the future look like
in the you know remaining three minutes
give me give me some hope or don't you
know I could tack on two hours yeah
maybe mine either for that question
um what does the future look like well I
always say that I'm a world-weary
optimist I'm an optimist ultimately
because I don't know how you could do
what we do meaning talk about the world
and explore all this stuff if you didn't
have some level of optimism because
otherwise
well first off this would be depressing
as hell but I don't know how I could
wake up and do it right but but it to
say why you describe myself as
world-weary because as I think I said
before I'm a realist I think first you
know I don't I see the world as it is
known as I want it to be you know like I
want the world to be a certain way but
that doesn't mean it is you know what
happens is with a lot of these the
Marxist the leftist whatever they are
they just want the world to be a certain
way so they demand that it be that way
yeah and they'll burn everything down in
the process I think here's what I
generally could see as a we're if we're
trying to get a roadmap to some sanity
in the future well I think Trump has to
win yeah yeah I think like that's just
it you think it really matters 2020 is
yeah you know I've been thinking about
this a lot it's like you know every
election now this is the most important
election ever that's never been more
important you know our values or
this time it's like man if he doesn't
win anything that we remember about
America and I don't say this is some
rah-rah Trump guy they're burning down
the buildings in there they're here to
ruin to wreck the entire thing yeah
they're here it's yeah the ship has
arrived on the shore do we want to just
sit there and watch as they burn our
houses down or do we want to do
something this is also the irony of the
people that I'm even more frustrated
with them you know the crazy leftist I'm
like not even frustrated by them anymore
because it's kind of funny but I would
say the never Trump conservatives you
know this is all three of these Bulworth
Bill Kristol David from crumple where
it's like you guys just want to be liked
by lefties yeah they're funded by love
yes yes you want to be liked by lefties
you didn't want to do anything or
conserve anything really you want to go
to nice parties so I want to conserve
their paychecks and their yeah that's
what they was in the mirror yeah and I
don't like to attack people's motives
but it's almost impossible for those
guys expired what I would say is Trump
has to win now not that that will stop
this because it will then cause it to
freak out even more so I think we're in
weren't for for more crazy years for
sure yeah the only way we're in for for
more crazy years that at least continue
freedom and capitalism is through Trump
what I think really is the is the
pivotal year of all of this because this
can't go on forever no yeah no movement
goes on forever right eventually it
either spins out of control in a
horrific way or it it perhaps winds down
or something in the middle
I think 2024 even though nobody wants to
hear the word 2024 my gosh I think
that's where this thing really gets
reset
I think if Trump wins again we'll have
had eight years of Trump people will be
exhausted by it but we'll have survived
the intersectional collectivist lunacy
and then you know what happens you're
gonna get a crop of Republicans like Dan
Crenshaw and Tim Scott and maybe Candace
Owens that she will be old enough and
yeah yeah maybe ben shapiro maybe
Michael knows nikki Haley you'll get
maybe not even for president but like
you will get a crop and I only want the
top job
you will get a crop of truly intellect
intellectually diverse people who care
know about America like
Trump again I don't have Trump
arrangement syndrome I'm most likely
voting for Trump um you know I like I
don't actually see why would you go way
around of course yeah but but no I mean
I am voting for Trump I can't see you I
just literally can't see your way around
it you know it's just it just is what it
is
yeah and now I'll be canceled by the
time I well I know that's over you said
it there was a mistake I knew these 15
shoulda gotten animosity but there will
be a set of people who know about
America who know about what our founding
values aren't like you could love Trump
but the idea that he's like a
constitutionalist or any of these things
I think it's sort of silly but he's he's
the he's the tough guy doing the job
that somebody had to do it just yes
but I think 2024 is where the reset
happens but we are in for a crazy ride
over the next couple years and and you
and I have discussed this you know we're
here in LA and I was considering bailing
on LA you were with it all bailing on LA
and I want to stay and fight because
maybe we can change some of this so
again I'm I don't think we just can
because we wish it to be I'm a
world-weary optimist I believe that if I
fight and you fight and the rest of us
fight maybe we can change that's kind of
an enigmatic positive note it reminds me
of the ancient Chinese curse may you
live in interesting times which is a
curse not a blessing you know most
people think it's blessed but you know
it might in a way it's sort of but who
said that because I feel like yeah you
should one more dead bird yeah I think
with Xi Jinping and he's definitely not
dead and that we are living in it
literally in a Chinese curse so I guess
I guess it all comes full circle Dave
you're the man thank you for giving me
an extra 15 medals I don't want to see
you for another I know we got to do
another hour-long interview tomorrow
dumper in this book get don't burn this
book Rita you know I really enjoyed it
especially for a long weekend great
thing to read and go to locals calm and
go to every other like five million
baths this guy is get out there thank
you sir appreciate you
[Music]
[Music]